i mean that whole thing was really fun
and special for me
um we'd met um
before but not not like that
um and the first day that we got to work
together was a scene
with a lot of improv potential in it and
we just had a great time i was like
whatever you
give me i'm gonna send it back to you
and uh
you know what i mean as it was just like
electric
wow and then throughout the rest of
making that movie we we went back at one
point and
uh got a bunch of scenes they they
totally changed the ending
um and we shot a bunch of pickup stuff
and even that was just
hilarious it's just so much fun um
you know he's truly one of my heroes
um getting to know him even
peripherally um and getting to work with
him is
like one of my proudest things
did you ever notice anything because you
know he's always the happy guy i always
i can relate where i you know i go not
to robin williams obviously he's
brilliant i'm just saying in terms of
like always being the center of
attention i always felt like as a kid
i've always
i felt like that was the only way i
could get in and and
you know it was did you feel like did
you ever see the real side of him did
you think did you ever
see a innate sort of sadness or anything
like that or was it always just kind of
fun and
fun and uh you know good times no we i
got i got to spend a couple of really
quiet moments with him and i was i was
even grateful for that we we did an
extensive amount of press
for that movie including like a whole um
golden globe uh a series of
interviews with the farm press and i i
was just with him
that whole day and it was a long day
and we um
had lunch together in his room
um and really we're just quiet
like just sat in the quiet because it
had been so noisy it had been so chaotic
and i took his comfort in
not needing to perform for me um
and me not needing to entertain him
yeah you know the i didn't know that he
was sick
and he didn't let on that he was
struggling
with um his interpretation of things
um but i did see him in between
scenes right so like when
uh uh lillard and dax and i were working
together
in between scenes we were just like
you know what i mean right keeping that
five and robin in between
scenes would just go sit in a quiet
corner and play
sudoku
sudoku just like brain challenges yep
brain challenges just
brain challenge video game brain
challenges and we talked a lot about
comics and video games and he
he just graciously consumed stuff
wow but i didn't realize in that time
that he was
struggling with cognition with
interpretation with uh even basic motor
function
and nobody knew nobody knew until after
and uh
you know i had bobcat on the show a
while back and he talked about it
because he was close friends with him
and they he he opened up a little bit
about that
and uh it's tragic it's like i think a
lot of people
that we know we always see this fun
loving hey how are you but we don't
really know what they're going through
or what they do when they go home or
what
you know kind of like the the clown with
the painted face and the painted smile
and sometimes we we don't know exactly
and so
you know i have a you know on this show
i always talk about
mental health and you know you never
know what other people are going through
and so
it's just important to to try and just
like you said be kind
be nice